President Biden facing some fresh
backlash for his sanitize for his
presidential political protection as I
put it visit to the border and thousands
of illegal immigrants Crossing into the
United States not any of whom he
actually saw I don't even know how
that's possible construction work
continues on a barrier surrounding his
Delaware Beach home oh that's nice why
for increased security of course and
it's going to cost taxpayers five
hundred thousand dollars Brian yeah so I
guess if walls do work uh so it's built
around the side of his house it's going
to close five hundred thousand dollars
against taxpayers are picking it up it's
a big white wall daily mail picked it up
took a picture and I think it's ironic
where he continues to say walls don't
work he continues to push to try to get
the shipping containers off the Border
makeshift barriers just to slow down
would-be illegals and at the same time
puts on his house when it comes to the
Border that's just a bad idea that the
Vikings came up with it we should have
dropped it the Viking not the Minnesota
Vikings
[Laughter]
who had the curtain
uh no the the iron that was steel uh
Steelers Steelers I knew somebody had a
career right it was the same year though
the 1970s purple people before you were
born oh I wish not even true I don't
even think NFL was around when I was
born uh Emily this also speaks to
perhaps why the borders are doesn't feel
the imminence or the urgency of disaster
at the border she too lives in a state
with a wall that's right and you would
think she would have been a participant
or at least commented on acknowledged
Biden having his layover there in El
Paso before he was on his way to The
Summit in Mexico City uh frankly it just
is one more indication that this
Administration doesn't actually care
they had to have a sanitized view of El
Paso they botched the statistics by the
way our president did with president
obrador of Mexico when he tried to talk
about fentanyl he's not even adequately
or accurately briefed he has been in a
manufactured bubble for quite some time
which includes a wall and remember what
he called Trump's wall he called it the
physical embodiment of Trump's inability
to develop effective immigration policy
and yet after he went down to El Paso he
used the first image he used to tout
that visit was a wall so why is he
making that that synonym that that
parallel between El Paso the wall which
by the way as we saw the wall actually
stops at El Paso so you can look into
Juarez huge quite easily and you can see
why there is an absolute lack of any
type of barrier that's why everyone down
there by the way in Juarez and El Paso
they just say it's a line it's not a
border it's just a line in Arizona and
we actually have a structure in Nogales
here you go it's still it's because the
fentanyl is flowing and our men and
women are doing everything they can to
try to stop it
um so Carly here's a question for you
because Governor Abbott opened my eyes
to this yesterday part of the cleaned up
Optics were provided by Texas taxpayers
yes because just a couple of weeks ago
he put those containers in place and
that helped stem the tide then the
president wanted them removed in Arizona
yeah yeah so so but he waited until the
the tide had been stimmed a little bit
he goes down there and then suddenly he
can see oh you know maybe maybe a wall
yeah he did the same thing in Yuma
Arizona where the Democrat mayor there
said that we're in trouble okay well
here's a little money for building out
some structure I mean this is a
piecemeal and it is political yeah
exactly it's a lot of false Optics in
politicking happening right now and
speaking of the political element of
this uh President Biden supported the
secure offense act when he was a senator
in 2006 which appropriated money for 700
miles of border wall he also voted in
favor of uh no he also supported jailing
employers who hire illegal immigrants
and said Sanctuary City should not be
allowed to violate federal law and he
said offense would need was needed to
stop drugs coming in from corrupt Mexico
so 17 years ago President Biden informed
president Trump were the same person on
this issue imagine that and now flash
forward to to today he's in Mexico he's
talking to Lopez obrador and he really
does have a good chance of possibly
stemming the flow of drugs and Fentanyl
in this country we had Derek maltz on
Fox and Friends first great guest a
former D.A Special Operations director
he used to lead operations targeting
Mexican drug cartels and he says you can
fix this issue secure the Border must
push Mexico to shut down the chemical
weapon production labs and he also said
start demanding the extradition of
kingpins back to the United States like
El Chapo's son yeah they don't care
about being in prison in Mexico their
big fear is being in prison in the
United States declare them as terrorists
which is what governor Abbott wants to
do I think it's fascinating that you
drew a picture for us of Biden back in
the day I didn't even think that he
would recognize that person exactly yeah
or maybe that person wouldn't recognize
the guy today well I think he wants to
get back to that person I I think we're
seeing him making moves right now
because he sees the 2024 election coming
up I would also point out that we have
spent billions and billions of dollars
in this Omnibus Bill and in our defense
budget to make sure that there are
secure borders for Ukraine and for
Israel and around Joe Biden's house but
for some reason this one this one is a
problem for him and he's walking along
that wall I think for a reason because I
think he's going to start walking back
this obviously there's nothing
interesting position obviously there's
nothing you can do except have a secure
border maybe that's right Marcia
Blackburn Tennessee senator took a
delegation of all women to the southern
border she actually was an Eagle pass
the Del Rio sector which we know has had
human catastrophe with young people
people of all ages drowning in the the
Rio Grande trying to get here she was on
the Faulkner focus last hour talking
about the Border crisis and brought up
some interesting points watch
you look at the women and the children
that are in these groups it is
heartbreaking and what we do know is
that the humanitarian crisis doesn't
stay here on the southern border the
drugs the human trafficking The Gangs
the sex trafficking the crime in our
cities the drugs that are in our
communities it is causing a humanitarian
crisis in our country
Martha you know uh Marshall Blackburn's
making a great point the untold story or
the story that needs to have a lot more
attention I've thought for a long time
is the human trafficking situation and
there are people who are dedicating
their entire lives in this country to
stopping the human trafficking that's
going on down there these young girls
who are told basically if your family
pays this amount of money will get you a
job in the United States they get here
and they are being pimped essentially
and they have no agency whatsoever so I
give her Senator Blackburn a lot of
credit and those folks and also there
their trip pointed out exactly what the
president didn't see and it's not so
tough to have your eyes open and say
let's go no you know like we said
yesterday just drop me in there and
don't tell anyone I'm coming because I
want to really see what's going on how
many points would he win for that on all
sides
and that's not what we saw with Biden
hey everyone I'm Emily compagno catch me
and my co-host Harris Faulkner and
Kaylee mcineny on outnumbered every
weekday at 12 p.m Eastern or sets your
DVR also don't forget to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page for daily
highlights